and here comes chris bubich he has
pitched very well in his last two
appearances and he pitched very well in
his one appearance against the white sox
this year
and there it is and it's hooked to the
left side dozier bare hands throws in
time oh man that's nice that's how you
pick up your pitcher right there already
man he came hard after that bare handed
it
threw off his right leg perfect throw
got him
lucas giolito on for his 21st start era
of three and three quarters a lot of
strikeouts 136 of them just 38 walks
patrol's been really good left-handers
because of that change-up hasn't done
much with them
oh two from lucas is a good sharp
fastball in one go on
when lucas has that fastball right
around 95 there's a little extra life to
it
and he gets it by mary field three and
two swing and a miss all that dazzling
change up he got the local
and two down if he's getting the high
change up
he's got the low changeup andrew vaughn
against left-handers he is slugging 6-10
1-2
curveball chopper again past boobage
dozier has no play and that
is the first base runner of the ball
game for the sox danny mendick
and now breaking ball was deflected by
bubic to whit
and in time one four three here's sebby
zavala
zavala is down on three pitches
and that's bubich's first strikeout
tonight and really only one hard hit
ball that was off the bat of anderson
who lined to short and now he loops one
to short
nikki lopez goes out to make the play
and down go the white sox in order in
the third hunter dozier batting for the
first time set up right in the middle of
the plate and there is a third slider
for strike three oh and two for taylor
geo hunting his fourth strikeout and
there it is another slider diving away
and two down
scoreless tie
adam all for one
adam shears this ball down the right
field line toward the corner it goes and
solaire
picks it out of the corner adam into
second with a leadoff double the always
dangerous alloy jimenez the bottom line
is just executing pitches you go out to
who like that right there man that's
exactly what you like to see lubach
needs to get mankata
bubitz gets him with a change up and
works around a runner at third with one
out oh man that is excellent
one two change up
and strikeout number five for lucas
giolito the royals are hitless through
four ladies attempt
andrew vaughn first in the fifth then
garcia and mendic
that is smoke to center field another
hard shot from andrew vaughn
right-handed laori out of all arms and
legs the pitch
lined into center over a leaping
merrifield for a base hit bond stops at
second and they've got something cooking
here in the fifth so here's danny
mendick
danny up the middle into center field
andrew vaughn to third he is on his way
home throw is offline tossed down his
second base and they have mendic caught
in a rundown behind the play here comes
run number two and garcia scores it's
two nothing socks
nice base running play by garcia yes you
give up the out but the sox get two runs
it's not as surprising on whit
merryfield he forgot about the most
important thing and that is not danny
mendes mendic drives home one but
maryfield's a pretty smart player so
there's a one-run scores and now mendic
gets trapped maryfield doesn't look at
all at leary and when liuri sees that he
didn't pay attention to him he scores
jorge solaire leads off the bottom of
the fifth for kansas city
was terrifying there's strike three nice
fastball lucas strikes out solaire lucas
giolito turns kicks and throws
and a drive the other way deep left
vaughn at the fence he's got it up
against the chain link fence in front of
the bullpen he banged into that barrier
and he just dropped ben and tandy what a
play two out and ryan o'hearn the batter
[Applause]
now we'll see what kind of a fielder he
is he stumbled and
with that short arm delivery throws late
well he he had a hard time getting off
the mound i don't know if he slipped or
if he was just shocked that the ball was
skewed like that but if brian o'hearn he
will take it and so are the royals
here's an 0-1
there's a line drive to left vaughn
dives makes the catch he's done it again
why not had to come in on that ball it
was dipping and diving left his feet
made to catch one down for nikki lopez a
one-two
this time he got him
hit the mitt right on the outside corner
cheeto alito's next offering is swung on
by wit
driving vaughn back to the wall he
reaches up and can't make the play the
ball bangs away merrifield will hold at
second base
with a likely double bond good route
perfect line right to it and just
couldn't get to it let's see on this
shot here yeah he missed it one-on-one
on salvi
salvi hits it deep to right field
garcia goes into the corner and it's off
of his glove
so another break defensively the royals
got one last inning and weren't able to
cash it in and we'll see what they do
with salvi's lead off double now solaire
and that's going to get through zavala
and get salvi to third
and he will do that deep to left and
off the top of the fence
and now he better hurry to get to second
will be in there as the throw comes in
wild
and solaire will go to third hey now
savvy loves that fastball we know go
ahead
put a home run in that category
there it is
oh my
how far
that was almost too far to be a salvi
splash
hey thank you fan for getting savvy and
pumped up with that sign you made but
i'll tell you what and that was powerful
that was high and far and you want to
call in a majestic homer that's exactly
what that was clutch homer we just
showed you the clutch
numbers after the seventh inning this
added a seventh homer to that category
take a look at this swing on the replay
that's a fastball groove belt high and
he did not disappoint he brought all the
fans here at kauffman stadium to their
feet in one swing
and a big roar that was really high and
far alberto is the hitter
run is down
and moncada double clutches
garcia covers so 5-4 and the winning run
is at third with one out
dozier hits it on the ground contact
play
and now a rundown and now ben and tendy
will stay in as long as he can to get
dozier into scoring position
no tag the game is over
white sox have a stunned look and tony
la
doesn't need to ask his replay guy
and
he is going to be out
taylor is over three tonight but he
lined out in the sixth inning against
giolito to left
taylor grounds it up the middle
base hit here's dozier
and the royals win it in the bottom of
the tent
michael a taylor what a clutch hit that
one stayed right with it up that shot it
right back at the biggest hole in the
diamond there royals won it two
different times in the bottom of the
10th inning
they were all over salvador perez's home
run was outstanding it was a beautiful
thing and let's not forget about boobage
so down but not out michael a taylor
puts the ball in play the royals win it
3-2